[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today hey Paige
welcome to the
show hello uh my question is or I guess
uh my husband doesn't want to try and
budget every time I bring it up it's
this big fight about who spends most
money on the most worthless things and I
don't know how
to handle that it's beyond that it's the
tip for Tat game you did this well I did
that well you do this so how are when
when these conversations come up let's
kind of retro back a little bit when
these conversations have come up have
they come up in the Heat of the Moment
or has it been like hey honey or hey boo
whatever you call your spouse I want to
sit down and talk here's what I'd like
to talk about you know um is it that
sort of thing or is it just like this is
happening out of the heat of a moment of
somebody opening up a bill for
something I it wouldn't say it's nor
like the key to the moment but it's
always like when we go paycheck to
paycheck week after week you always
scraping the barrel and then I'm like
hey Canim you try this and then he like
gets super mad about it and then it's
just paycheck to paycheck it's the same
thing you just want to break that cycle
um yeah part of it I think I think part
of it how you approach it I think that
if instead of uh attack the conversation
as we need to stop doing this you know
we're just living paycheck to paycheck
you know that we've got to start getting
on a budget I think if you kind of
approach it in the way of um I'm really
I'm really worried and I'm really scared
and I've just been noticing like my
anxiety is going nuts and I think it's
because we're overspending I think it's
because we are not on the same page and
I'd really like to be on the same page
what does that look like to you like I'd
kind of throw the ball on their Court of
like what do you think that looks like
and that way it's not you saying not
necessarily coming in saying this is
what we need to be doing but just
opening up that conversation have you
tried
that I have tried that and I've suggest
a few different things like hey we put
wer paychecks into the joint account for
bills and such you can put x amount I
use like $300 for an example into your
own personal account to spend it on what
you want your own gas station whatever
and then once you go past that you can't
dip into the uh yeah
okay so paig already can I say this
already it's becoming a paig is telling
what's your husband's name or if you
don't want say well Bob Bob we'll come
Bob we okay
okay uh it's already you almost in a
maternal role of okay we're going to put
your money here and you can't do this
and this this this it it is still this
hierarchy of you being the kind of
authority in a sense and so the goal
would be just to paint you a picture is
that you are both a team you both are
equal in this he has as much say in this
as you do you have as much say as he
does and it's you guys together saying
oh yeah this and this and this and this
versus one telling one what to do if
that makes sense and so um yeah no that
makes sense yeah and I would say this
too with an aster there's naturally
always going to be more of the nerd and
there's naturally always going to be the
free spirit so like Winston forever will
love sell and love the budget and love
painting out what investments of this
this this more than me which is funny
cuz this is my job and this is like what
I do every day but he actually is more
of the numbers and thrives on that and
more of the Savor than I am so he won't
change who I am but the way we approach
our money together can still be as a
team so always know that you still will
have your own personalities he may never
just love the budget like Paige does and
that's okay but as long as you're both
in it together that's going to be the
goal so I would want to know do do you
do you know his hesitation what what it
is that he kind of pushes back against
and why or why he pushes back against
it I think he likes to kind of be in
control a little bit um I know he's
always brought fact that before we even
got together I had no problem you know
with my money but so he's trying to kind
of make it you're the blame kids are the
BL but live or like our lives have
changed since we met you know sure we
live in a different place and things are
more expensive and two kids to do
through daycare and yep so I would ask
him then back just to keep the
conversation going I think Jade's
Point's really good is like I want to
hear from him and so like okay so you're
saying that before all of this you were
you know you you didn't have money
problems which to a degree duh because
you didn't have all these expenses right
that's what we're all thinking but also
what what were what did you have in
place that worked really well because he
may have his own way of doing stuff that
you know you don't see uh that maybe you
actually could Implement and so I think
again it's going back to this like it's
this team mentality which I know is so
easier said than done page cuz we're
about to get off the air here in five
minutes and and go home and I know
you're the one that's having to have
these conversations but as much as you
guys can sit down and say gosh I feel
like this is pinning us against each
other mhm and we can't be against each
other like we are in this together and
we both want to win like like no one
wants to choose to have a stressful
anxious life and marriage and so and no
one's trying to say whose fault it is
like if you and Bob can both agree this
the problem is it's us it's us like
we're we're paycheck to paycheck both of
us don't like that both of us would love
to get to a point where we've got
savings and you know we we're out of
debt like if you guys can surround that
and like lock arms around that and
that's where you're going to move
forward yeah and sometimes Paige
especially with guys that's kind of a
stereotype so it may not be true for him
but I have found like when you can put
numbers and actual facts instead of just
ideas and theories of cutting back and
all this when you actually see numbers
down sometimes it helps because you can
actually blame the numbers instead of
blaming each other and so I would just
say hey one night like after dinner can
we please will you and just ask them can
you will you just give me an hour and I
want to pull out the bills and I just
want to look and like what if I just
want to and help me do it right bring
him in that you're Paige isn't bringing
everything and Paige isn't telling what
the numbers are together we're having a
conversation so will you just sit down
because I want to know like okay what
are you spending on Gest and you guys
just make this puzzle and lay out the
numbers and kind of just do a mock
budget together again try I don't want
it to be conflict filled or tension
filled this is just bringing numbers to
the table uh and let that be a starting
point because I think sometimes
in our heads things can be magnified in
our heads things can be isolating
there's so much that if we just keep up
in our head and in our mind it just can
go sideways and when things are down and
you're looking at actual facts and
looking at actual
numbers sometimes not always but
sometimes that kind of like diffuses the
tension um because you see that and then
from there you know look at the Tactical
and then also it's if it's going well
that night or maybe it's another night
dream and just say hey yeah what would
it look like in 5 years what does our
life look like how old are our kids what
grade are they going to be in where do
we want to be like just start to like
have this vision of where you guys want
to be as a family and there's something
about being proactive in that that is so
inspiring than just living life paycheck
to paycheck month to month and you look
up and it's been five years and you
don't know where you know you don't know
where you're going and so having that I
think is really key too page but just
know you're not alone in this this is
one of the biggest problems we hear from
people is that one spouse is on board
and wants to do this and another isn't
so you're not alone in it and also we've
heard so many couples on our debt free
stage say gosh I wasn't on board I
thought y'all were crazy and and then
finally we all I got on board and
together we did this so even couples who
win start out where you guys are so have
hope pig that this can change it it
really can but I think it's really the
way you approach it don't be the mom
definitely don't be the mom have a
humble Spirit about it um but bring you
know this conversation it's a
conversation to be had it's not pointing
fingers and and blame even this picture
of put the numbers out in front of you
and like lock arms and like it's us
against you numbers like you know what I
mean it's not us against each other so
it's good uh it's powerful Paige that's
a it's a big part of winning is you and
your spouse and just for the sake of
your marriage not just your money for
the sake of your marriage I pray that um
that this brings you guys together so
thanks for the call